time now for pft on yahoo sports peter
king and mike florio here with you big
stories in the nfl nothing bigger than
the super bowl but peter pro football
amid a pandemic so far the nfl is 268
for 268 all games have been played
and i would suspect
that there are some in the league office
that wish that the super bowl would be
played this sunday not the following
sunday because of the potential that
guys who aren't locked into a game
coming up in what would be only six days
away could end up getting coveted 19.
strange week for these two teams as they
try to remain free of the virus peter
i think that's a great point mike and
we'd be naive to think that
uh
these two rosters are going to go 106
for 106 you know with
53 active guys on each roster you know
being fine on game day um
i i mean i think it's i think the odd
part of this week is it's going to feel
even with one of the great
quarterback match-ups in super bowl
history
you know the best player of today versus
the best player of yesterday
and
both of them are
still going to be great in 2021 by the
way
uh
you know when you when you sort of look
at this
man how great it would be to celebrate
it and to be clubbed over the head
you know for 13 days before the game
and it's going to get a lot of talk
obviously but it's not going to be the
same with the teams not being unseen
with doing zoom calls without being in
public and and all that stuff it's just
going to be weird it's just going to be
very weird chiefs probably won't go into
tampa until friday or saturday it's just
it's going to be a totally different
super bowl
but i still think
6 37 or whatever time the game is on
super sunday um people are going to be
pretty fired up for mahomes brady 5.
yeah absolutely and all we can hope for
is that they get to that point without
anything that would undermine the
competitive aspect of the game and it's
locked in it's going forward they're not
going to postpone it
you know they look we've been down this
road many times throughout the season
and there's every reason to believe
they'll be able to keep this on the
right track but they do have that extra
time now to worry about it i remember
when the buccaneers had their bi-week
week 13 that was one of the things that
bruce airings was concerned about stay
on the right side of the virus and you
know with team leaders like tom brady
and others i i i this is it this is your
moment this is your time i think the
challenge though is this and aryans
talked about this yesterday if you've
got people coming in from out of town
that's where you need to be even more
careful you don't know
what your house guests may bring to you
and that's how you may end up getting
exposed to it
the dallas cowboys did a brilliant thing
late in this year jerry jones around i
think thanksgiving it was he may have
also done it for christmas he had a
testing site he opened up the cowboys
testing site in frisco texas to all
visitors all family visitors
and
you know there was an unofficial thing
among the cowboys do not have anyone
enter your house
until they have undergone testing
and everybody did it front office did it
coaches did it anybody was going to be
around the players
if i were
the nfl if i were either one of these
teams that's the rule i'd have in place
uh during super bowl week
yeah absolutely and you know one of the
things that started last week that
hasn't gotten a lot of publicity the nfl
actually has individuals from the league
office who are in the team facilities
just making sure that the protocols are
being followed because all year long the
nfl is accepted guys are going to get it
away from work the challenge is making
sure that the guys who inevitably come
through the door and we're not going to
find out until that night or the next
morning that they tested positive making
sure that none of those guys give it to
anyone else peter and that's where the
nfl's protocols have performed
incredibly well
i think one of the things you know you
saw the nfl uh this week combined uh
sort of with the cdc with the cdc
crediting the nfl for being able to
keep up its business in a pandemic it's
like what alan stills said to me in
august mike
america should be rooting for us to
succeed
because we can show the country how if
you really try if you really want to if
you have the will
you know you will be able to beat this
pandemic or conduct business
during this pandemic the nfl has had the
will america sadly has not
also helps to have enough money to pay
for your own private testing capacity
that's a different issue altogether
though that's it for now he's peter king
i'm mike floria we'll see you next time
[Music]
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports